[موسيقى]
اوقات اعزائي المشاهدين بانوراما من
العربيه يقدمه لكم صهيب شراير هذه
مواضيعها بعد قطيعه دامت 11 عاما خطوات
للتطبيع التركي السوري لماذا العوده وماذا
ينتظر كل طرف من الاخر لماذا
الظواهري رسميا حتى الان ولما التكتم على
خليفه
هل ركود العام الجديد حتمي ما هو حجمه
وسبل تجنبه او حتى التقليل من تداعياته
تقارب تركي سوري صاحبه تحقيق خطوات مهمه
في خارطه التطبيع بين البلدين عوده المسار
الصحيح وفقا للبلدين في العلاقات بات
وشيكا فانقرا ابدت عدم ممانعه مشروطه
للانسحاب من الارض السوريه التي تسيطر
عليها ليعود معها الى الاذهان تصريحات
اردوغان عندما قال بانه لا خلاف ابدي في
السياسه ولقائي بالاسد يمكن ان يحصل في
الاطار الذي يخدم الامن القومي التركي لكن
التفاصيل الجديده حملتها هذه المره
تصريحات وزير الخارجيه التركي الذي اكد ان
تطور العلاقات مع النظام السوري مرتبط
بعض الخطوات في العمليات السياسيه قبل
لقاء الرئيس التركي بالرئيس السوري
العلاقات التركيه السوريه ومنذ عام 2012
ابتسمت بالتوتر وبعد ان اغلق تركيا سفرتها
في دمشق بسبب قمع نظام الاسد للمتظاهرين
وصفتهامات المتعدده الاطراف بين اردوغان
الذي الاسد بالمجرم وبشار الذي وصف
اردوغان بالاخوانجي الاجير لدى امريكا
[موسيقى]
سالم ديكتاتور
لازمته
خالص
[موسيقى]
ساند
را
ليه
من اسطنبول ومن دمشق ومن باريس
من اسطنبول ومن دمشق عبد الحميد توفيق
الكاتب الصحفي ومن باريس المحلل العسكريه
السوريه عبد الناصر العايد مرحبا بكم
ضيوفي الكرام شكرا لكم
لماذا العوده الان لتطبيع العلاقات بين
سوريا وتركيا بعد كل هذه القطيعه بين
البلدين
مساء الخير لك صهيب ولضيوفك الكرام
والاساده المشاهدين اعتقد بانها حكايه
سياسيه لا اكثر ولا اقل وبمعنى مختصر بان
المصالح اليوم تلاقت بين البلدين او بين
النظامين او بين القيادتين التركيه
والروسيه كل الحسبه بواعثه وكل حسب اهدافه
ومراميه من هذا التقرب كان هناك كثير من
الاحاديث عن ان مثل هذا التقارب قد لا
يحصل بسبب المعطيات التي حدثت خلال العقد
الماضي من الزمن اثناء الاحداث في سوريا
وما تط- تطور ال- ال- العداء الملحوظ على
المستويات الشخصيه والدوليه بين الجانبين
وبين الرئيسين وكل هذه المعطيات ادت الى
تنافر وعداوه كبيره اليوم اعتقد بان
الحاله التحول في المنطقه وتحديدا ما يسعى
اليه الجانب التركي من خلال التحولات التي
يسعى همم
الولوج اليها في المنطقه في تصالحه مع مصر
مع الرياض مع الخليج العربي وكذلك يعتقد
بان الجاء اعتقد بان الجانب الاهم في
تحفيز الرئيس التركي اردوغان والجانب
التركي هو المساله الداخليه ايضا فيما
يتعلق بملف الانتخابات او موضوع
الانتخابات الذي بدا الموضوع السوري بكل
عناوينه اللاجئين الوجود التركي في الشمال
السوري دعم بعض الفصائل السوريه المسلحه
المعارضه المسلحه وكذلك احتواء جبهه
النصره في بعض مناطق ادلب كل ذلك حفل اكثر
لان الوقت ضاغطا على جانب التركي
بان العامل الروسي هو عامل مرجح لكل هذه
المساله والذي كان يسعى منذ فتره طويله
لجمع الجانبين وانهاء حاله العذاب بين
الطرفين نعم ضيفي من اسطنبول سيد طه عوده
اوغلو ما رايك في مقاله ضيفي من دمشق هل
تلاقي المصالح بين اردوغان والاسد عبر
الوسيط الروسي هو ما يقارب
همم رئيسين في المرحله التاليه
نعم تحياتي لك يا استاذ صهيب ضيوفك الكرام
والساده المشاهدين دون شاكر انا اتفق يعني
الوطن هو فقط كل شيء اعتقد هذه هي العباره
التي يريد ارسالها الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان للجميع وان المصالح هي تتغير
بتغيير الظروف الجوسيه ولكن تحدثنا عن ان
تقارب التركي مع النظام السوري هو ليس
جديده يعني هو تقريبا منذ التدخل الروسي
في سوريا في عام 2015 وهناك قناعه تركيه
همم بان خاصه بعد التطورات التي حصلت على
سعيد علاقات التركيه الروسيه بعد اسقاط
الطائره هناك نوعا ما لاحظنا تقارن وتقارب
كان عبر المسار استخبارات تتذكر ولكن ايضا
هناك على المسار خارج عن مسار الداخلي بعد
انتخابات 2019 كان هناك خساره للحزب
الحاكم حزب العداله والتنميه في
الانتخابات البلديه هناك داخل انقره في
صناعه القرار همم اتخذوا قرار باعاده او
غرب السياسه الخارجيه وهذا ما تبعناه خلال
العام نصف من الان هناك سياسه تص مع عدد
كبير من دول المنطقه وحققت نجاحات واعتقد
المحطه الاخيره وجدت نظريه هي اا الى دمشق
وخاصه التواصل الذي حصل قبل فتره والخارطه
التي رسمها الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
قبل اسبوعين من الان المتعلقه بهناك
لقاءات على المستوى استخبارات الخارجيه
الدفاع الخارجيه وما القاده لحتى هذه
اللحظه تحقق البند الاول والثاني ونحن
بصدد تحقيق البند الثالث كما تحدث وزير
الخارجيه التركي قبل يومين من الان نعم
ضيفي من باريس سيد عبد الناصر اجدد ترحيب
بك معنا يعني ما هي هذه المصالح التي تنهي
هذه العداوه الكبيره جدا التي استمرت
لاكثر من عقد الان خاصه بين شخصين
الرئيسيين اردوغان والاسد
مساء الخير صهيب يعني نحنا لنفهم التطورات
الاخيره لازم نفهم السياق الاكبر الاوسع
بالفعل كما قال ضيفك من اسطنبول المساعي
الروسيه والايرانيه لجمع النظام مع مع
انقره
منذ زمن طويل ليست جديده وهناك يعني
محاولات سابقه فشلت و ااا
استمرت الضغوط الروسيه على تركيا لكي يعني
تقوم بهذه الخطوه وقد نجحت بالفتره
الاخيره همم بسبب عاملين رئيسيين العام
الاول داخلي ابنه ان الرئيس اردوغان يواجه
مشكله انتخابيه عويصه وموقعه وموقع حزبه
مهدد في الانتخابات القادمه وسلاح
المعارضه الامضاء هو يعني موضوع اللاجئين
السوريين ثلاثه مليون ونصف لاجئ سوري في
تركيا
واعادتهم الى سوريا
على الاقل هو يريد ان يخلص المعارضه
التركيه من هذه الذريعه يعني ربما يقول
انه سيبدا بالعمليه او انه اتخذ خطوات
عمليه النقطه الثانيه الخطيره والمهمه
ايضا تتعلق
بالكيان الكردي في شمال شرق سوريا الحقيقه
تركيه لديها مخاوف ربما مبالغ بها جدا من
هذا الكيان وحاولت بالمؤخرا انه اردوغان
اذا حاول كجزء من عمليه يعني التجهيز
الانتخابات انه شل عمليه عسكريه لتخفيف
هذا القلق لتخفيف هذا لاجز لكنه وجه
بمعارضه امريكيه همم فاتجهها باتجاه
التصالح مع النظام لانه النظام الاسد من
حيث الشرعيه القانونيه الدوليه على الاقل
هو الوحيد القادر على تقويض الكيان الكردي
فهو اتخذ هذا القرار الاستراتيجي واتجه
بهذا الاتجاه هذين هذين العاملين هم برايي
اللي اللي سببه هذا التغير والتغير قد
يكون تكتيكي ما لم يستجيب للرغبه الروسيه
الرغبه الروسيه والرغبه الايرانيه هي
باطار عزل القضيه السوريه عن محيطها
العالمي الدولي اقصد وحلحالتها ضمن الدول
الاقليميه لفلفتها هنا يعني بين تركيا
وايران وربما عدد من دول العربيه
يصير انقلاب بعدين يعني ممكن يعني هذا
تقارب مرحله تطبيع في العلاقات مرحله ربما
ينتكس في وقت الماء هذا ما ترمي اليه
نعم نعم ممكن في حال طبعا في مرحله
الانتخابات يجب ان تمر لكن يحدث شيء قبل
ان يعني اردوغان تمر الانتخابات لكن يبقى
العامل الثاني الذي ذكرته لك وهو عامل
تقويض الكائن الكردي ربما يتضح مع مرور
الوقت النظام غير قادر على فعل شيء بسبب
الوجود الامريكي في الشمال شرق سوريا
اكبر الضحايا في هذا التقارب بين همم دمشق
وانقره ضيفه في دمشق همم الاستاذ عبد
الحميد توفيق عود همم ما رايك في ما قاله
ضيفي من باريس انه صحيح هناك همم تلاقي
مصالح الان بين تركيا وسوريا في هذه
المرحله ولكن حجم العداء الذي همم اتضح
خلال احد عشر عاما الماضيه خاصه بين
اردوغان والاسد همم انه قد يكون هذا تقارب
مرحله تقارب تكتيكي همم ما سيلبث ان ينفرض
عقده مره اخرى ما رايك هذا التقارب هو
قابل للانتاز
همم تمت معطيات على ارض الواقع اليوم همم
متمثله اولا بالمصالح التي باتت مشتركه في
ما يتعلق بالجانب السوري انه همم حصل كما
اعلن وزير الخارجيه التركي بان تركيا
مستعده للانسحاب من الاراضي التي يسيطر
عليها في الشمال السوري وفي الجانب التركي
ايضا حصلت تركيا على ضمانات حين يظهر
البيان الختامي لوزيري الدفاع السوري
والتركي برعايه الروسيه في مسلم قبل عده
ايام ويضع العنوان الاساسي انه تم الاتفاق
على مكافحه الارهاب وعلى ان حزب العمال
الكردستاني وذراعه السوري هما همم راس
الحربه في الارهاب الذي يتبع له اسرائيل
وامريكا اعتقد بان هذا العنوان كان كافيا
لان يشير الى ان هناك استراتيجيا مرسومه
بخطوات لاحقه في هذا الامر لا شك بانه
هناك مرحلتين اعتقد بان المرحله الاولى
تكتيكيه تقوم على ترتيب الاسس بين الطرفين
برعايه الروسيه وباداره الروسيه الى صحه
تعبير والبعد الاستراتيجي في ذلك هو ان
العواصمه الثلاث انقر دمشق موسكو اليوم
تقاطعت مصالحها في الروسي يريد ان ينايكف
الامريكي من خلال التحرش بالقوى الكرديه
التي تخضع لارادته في شمال شرق سوريا
والتركي اريد ان يحرض الطرفين الروسي
والسوري على ضغط على هذه الاطراف التي هي
كانت مقربه الىهما
السوريون ينظرون الى مثل هذه المساله
بانها بعد كل الذي بعد كل الطروحات التي
قدمت لي الجانب الكردي للتفاهمات على مدى
الاربع سنين الماضيه لم يكن هناك استجابه
كرديه الا بمطالب وسلطه
اليها استاذ عبد الحميد حقا همم يعني
تلاقي المصالح بين العواصم الثلاثه ليس
فقط بين انقره ودمشق همم سيد همم طه اغنه
في في اسطنبول همم هلا عدت لنا كذلك على
ما سيحصل عليه كل طرف هل تتفق مع ضيف كذلك
على انه روسيا هي تناك في ال- ال-
الامريكيين همم من خلال هذا التقارب
التركي السوري على حساب الاكراد الذين
تدعمهم همم امريكا ماذا كذلك ماذا ماذا
سيحصل كل طرف همم من خلال تطبيع العلاقات
بين سوريا وتركيا
يعني التصور اعتقد يعني قبل ان تتحدث عن
هذا الموضوع الذي دفع الجانب التركي
الذهاب للروس هم لامريكان يعني تتذكر
الرئيس تركيا اردوغان من زملاء الماضي حتى
اللحظه كان يهدد بشان عمليه عسكريه في
الشمال السوري
الامريكيه ما زالت تدعم قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه هذا دفع همم دفع عن انقره
لتوجه الى روسيا وايضا هناك مقترحات هذه
مقترحات الروسيه التي عرضت هنا في اسطنبول
كانت مقنعه بالنسبه للجانب التركي وخاصه
المتعلقه بالهاجسس الامني بالنسبه الاتراك
وابعاد هو قوات اسد عن حدودها كان هناك
انقره تحت امام بانه هناك مشروع امريكي
وهذا المشروع تاسيس كيان كردي على حدود
وهذا من خطوط الحمراء بالنسبه لتركيا تحدث
لك قبل قليل بان المشكله هي بدات او تقارب
التركي السوري بعد 2015 اللي حظنا ان هناك
عمليات بدات في 2016 التركي كانت تتحدث
قبل يعني في عام 2011 رحيل بشار الاسد
ولكن منذ 2006 لحتى اللحظه تتحدث عن
الهاجس الكردي لذا اعتقد ان العنوان
الابرز في هذا التقارب هو مكافحه الارهاب
وهذا تتحدث بها عن المسؤولين اتراك هنا
وهذا ما دفع الجانب التركي للتقارب مع
الجانب الروسي الذي هو اطمن انا نوعا ما
الاتراك في هذا الموضوع ويعتقد ان روسيا
صح يعني اتفق ان هي استغلت هذه الفرصه
وكانت هناك فرصه اخرى كانت مجلس سنوات
الفرصه
لتواصل ما بين انقره ودمشق وهذا ما تحقق
خلال ايام الاخيره الماضيه طيب همم سيد
عبد الناصر العائد في باريس همم
تبعنا كذلك انه مساله الاكراد الاكراد
سيكونون اكبر ضحايا هذا التقارب السوري
التركي والاكراد هم مدعمون من الامريكيين
هل ستستمر حمايه الامريكي للاكراد ام سي
يتخلون عنهم همم في همم ظل يعني هذه
الجهود الروسيه للتقريب بين تركيا وسوريا
همم سيدي ليست همم ليس الاكراد هم الخاسر
الاكبر الخاسر الاكبر هو الشعب السوري هو
المعارضه السوريه بمعناها يعني الذي
رايناه خلال عشر سنوات الاكراد لديهم حليب
وحليف قوي ولديه قوات على الارض الامريكان
يعني ما يعني جهه معها الامريكان لا يمكن
ان تكون خاسره من سيخسر هو من وضع كل
اوراقي ومفاتيح اللعب بالطرف وهذا الطرف
نكث بوعوده وبالتزاماته وطبعا انا ما بحمل
المساله يعني ابعاد اخلاقي لما باعتقد
بهذا الامر بالسياسه لكن المعارضه السوريه
بمعناها اللي عرفناه خلال 10 سنوات ماضيه
هي الخاصر اكبر وقد نشهد وقتها اذا لم
تتحرك بسرعه لتخرج من الربقه
همم
يعني لو تحدثنا عن الخاسرين لعل اكبرهم
كذلك اللاجئون السوريون يعني هم يعانون
الامرين
الموجوده حاليا همم من وجودهم والان مساله
رب اعادتهم الى الى سوريا الى اي حد يعني
في يعني فيما تبقى لدينا من الوقت مساله
اللاجئين كذلك همم كيف سيتم ادارتها اذا
ما عاده العلاقات بين تركيا وسوريا
باختصار شديد لو سمحت
نعم اعتقد ان هناك خطه تركيه وبالتعاون مع
روسيا لاسكان عدد كبير من اللاجئين ربما
مليون لاجئ في المنطقه الشريط الحدودي
التي ستحتفظ تركيا بادارتها في الفتره
القادمه لن يعود للاجئين الى النظام ليس
لديه ما يقيم اول من يجدون عنده اللي عنده
عام يهربوا فما بده كيف بده يجيب ناس
ثانيين ومين بده يرجع اساسا اللي عنده
اساسا هو ما بده اياها لاسباب سياسيه هذول
كلهم معارضين ومعارضين صار لهم عشر سنوات
خارجين من سيطرتهم ما بقدر يجيبهم اعتقد
انه هذول مثل ما حكيت حضرتك هم اللي راح
يعني يكونوا اللي بتقبض الضربه الكبرى
وعلى المعارض سوريا مسؤوليه البحث عن
مصلحتهم كما بحثت عن مصلحتها وذلك لايجاد
بلد اخر يستضيف الائتلاف السوري ربما تكون
اوروبا مناسب بدات تركيا في اسرع وقت نعم
نعم سيد عبد الحميد من دمشق لك حق التعقيب
همم لو سمحت
اعتقد بان ملف اللاجئين ملف داخلي مشترك
بين سوريا وانقره اردوغان يريد ان يلقي
بهذا العبي عن كتفه امام المعارضه ويسحب
هذه الورقه منهم وفي سوريا اعتقد بان
التوجه بعد ان اعلن وزير الخارجيه التركي
بان سوريا ترغب بعودتهم اعتقد ان هناك
ترتيبات ستكون مشتركه لرعايه الروسيه لكي
يكون هناك ضمان بالحد الادنى لعودته الى
ممتلكاتهم وديارهم وربما لمن
في الشمال السوري على الحدود مع تركيا حتى
يكون هناك يعني تبديد للوجود الكردي
لا اعتقد بذلك لان المناطق الشماليه التي
يتواجد فيها الان الاتراك والفصائل
السوريه المسلحه المعارضه لها اهلها ايضا
سيعودون اليها ولا هناك لاجئون في تركيا
من كل المحافظات السوريه وبالتالي يعتقد
ان التفاهم التركي الذي اعلن عنه مع
الجانب السوري انه سيكون هناك عوده لهم
بالحد الادنى ومن لا يرغب بالعوده فهذا
كما قال الجانب التركي في تصريحات الرسميه
شكرا جزيلا لك الاستاذ عبد الحميد توفيق
الكاتب الصحفي كنت معنا من دمشق من
اسطنبول الشكر لك الاستاذ طه عوده اوغلو
المحلل السياسي ومن همم باريس المحل
العسكريه السوري عبد الناصر العائد